meditation is the biggest gift that I
can give anyone and I would say more
than anything it is whatever reason for
Success I've had because back to the two
's I'll clarify what I mean is that in
your mind there we think what do you
want and the reality is when you look at
the neuroscience and
psychology that there are different
parts of your brain that want different
things and so in the simplest sense
there is the logical part of the brain
that you're conscious of it's called the
conscious and you think you're being
logical and you want to make those
decisions and then there's the
subliminal below the limic system part
of the brain which is the emotional and
it's not as conscious to you but it has
more of an influence on you than really
The Logical one and so they're not
aligned and so meditation helps to deal
with the alignment of those two things